you might have one maybe you're thinking
about getting one electric or
e-bikes if you tried to get one recently
you may be on a wait list
kate houston found booming business
bringing e-bikes to las vegas
and what you need to know before you buy
with the e-bike it totally changed our
lives
we go out all the time the phrase it's
as easy as riding a bike
just got easier if you want the exercise
you can pedal
and if you get tired you can use the you
know the power
and it's really great to be able to just
have something that's you know
environmentally friendly
and fun ginger allen is the latest to
join the growing movement of electric
bikes
we absolutely love it because las vegas
has a lot of hills
and unless you're like a professional
athlete and you have a lot of stamina
it's really not that fun to ride bikes
around here now new businesses are
popping up
like cactus e-bikes in the hopes of
expanding this trend in las vegas
and the surrounding scenery everyone
already knows downtown they know the
strip
people just it's still a revelation for
many people
what the outside of the the las vegas
fishbowl has to offer
with a wider tire and lightweight frame
cactus evike says these are great for
hitting the trails
this pop-up business offers tours
rentals and bikes for purchase
the average cost of an e-bike is
25-hundred dollars
dave essel grass says anyone can ride
them no matter your experience
they're super stable so for folks who
haven't been on a bike and worry about
keeping their balance
the tire is going to do it for you but
you'll need to buy quickly due to a
backlog of bikes that after this month
could take up to six months to arrive
if anything it just says we're in the
right space but you know the supply
chain issues have to work themselves out
kate houston 8 news now
we asked on twitter if you've been able
to buy one recently 27 percent said yes
73 percent
know join the conversation on twitter
and if you did get an e-bike tell us
where you found it and how much you paid
denise had been riding an old school
bike and people on e-bikes fly by me and
i'm like maybe i need more protein
did i not stretch enough it's tough